my name is Eddie ohm I went to Arizona
State University and I was part of Theta
Chi fraternity my name is Andre I'm a
days I went to University of California
Berkeley Sigma Epsilon oh my god my name
is Ryan I went to school at Missouri
State University I'm a Theta Chi hi my
name is DJ I went to Emerson College
Sigma Alpha Epsilon fraternity is
actually have paddles to signify the Big
Brother little brother process these
paddles aren't necessarily tools they
are displays or trophies it's like
having a plaque or like having something
that kind of lets you remember your time
in the fraternity I think that a lot of
fraternities do still haze sadly most of
it I think now revolves around drinking
in my experience the hazing wasn't that
bad during my sophomore year my
organization SAE abolish pledging like
yeah we had to drink a little bit here
and there bros mostly you know
memorization learning and you know the
chapter history
eternities are not businesses they're
nonprofits so they don't make money in
the sense of life we have this money now
we're keeping it but I mean returnees
have dues a portion of that do goes
towards your chapter another portion
goes towards your region and your sum
goes to like the national organization
[Music]
they have the real estate they have the
time they have the community and when
you combine all three of those you have
a party my fraternity is actually a
social one and the main focus is to
connect queer folks and allies so a lot
of it involved like social gatherings
[Music]
yes and no you're gonna meet a lot a lot
a lot of interesting people those people
are your friends for life if you are
truly being yourself you're around guys
that like you for you you're not just
paying for your friends because they're
gonna actually know you and actually
care about you and know who you are and
like you yes you're paying to be in a
fraternity but you're getting something
more out of it well I don't think I was
just paying for friends I think that I
was really giving my money towards
building a community but I really felt
it harmless
I do think returnees get a bad rep some
of them are deserved some are not
unfortunately there are chapters that do
terrible things and don't care about
being better people and so those
chapters get thrown in the news and it
makes it seem like everyone's bad as a
whole I do think a live fraternities a
lot of chapters get a bad rap a lot of
kids are really good kids who put an
emphasis on community service giving
back to different charities and whatnot
there's a big reason why almost every
chapter I can think of has some sort of
fundraising chair I don't think it
should get the rap that maybe people
perceive it to get because it does a lot
of good for the individual that is fresh
out of you know their home life their
home experience
[Music]
at my school there wasn't a lot of
diversity that is just true in my
fraternity there was definitely a year
when I was the only black guy and for me
I didn't feel unwelcome they were
definitely awkward occurrences and there
would be moments when people say
something I was offensive or something
that was like borderline racist and I
would have to call out like they were
definitely it was a learning experience
for both of us because I had never
really been in places where I had to
check someone for saying some that was
racist it helped me grow as a person it
helped me like kind of understand my
blackness more as a gender-neutral
transgender woman I would say that my
experience at my fraternity was really
unique for folks who think that it's a
super exclusive environment and it's the
only built for a certain type of people
I would say that's another assumption
about people have you know and so like
really do your research and make friends
and I mean like if you're interested
look for the people like you who are in
those spaces and of course you're gonna
have different views on things but
differences make us stronger as a
minority I felt very welcomed in my
chapter my school was not necessarily
the most diverse school while my chapter
was definitely more diverse the majority
of necessarily weren't so I think
definitely seen by more minorities
having them not be afraid to join of
like you know afraid of stereotypes and
whatnot because you could actually have
a really great time and meet some really
cool people
[Music]
it helped me manage different types of
people and managed being in spaces that
I'm not necessarily familiar with
definitely I would say the connections
from the Alumni alumni network that came
with it I came out to LA I didn't know
anyone except for the friends that I met
through my fraternity in school and I
still live in contact and live next to a
bunch of my friends that were my
fraternity brothers in college I'd say
Greek life was one of the most
foundational and fun experiences in my
life I value that that time
second-to-none
[Music]